[Musica]
ero al quinto mese di gravidanza
avevo 24 anni quando sono quasi caduta
in depressione non facevo altro che
piangere ogni giorno poi un mese dal
parto le cose sono cominciate ad andare
un po meglio ma non lucia frizzante
allegra che c'era il tempo con la
trovavo più la vita andata avanti tra
grandi gioie e dolori un po come per
tutti finché un giorno una mia amica
decide di regalarmi un corso di risata
incondizionata
non sappiamo bene di cosa si trattasse
ma non ridevo da così tanto tempo che
decisi accettare all'istante così
cominciando a ridere prima che la vita
mi desse un motivo per farlo mi sono
finalmente sentita di nuovo viva e ho
cominciato a sentire emozioni che non
provavo più da tantissimo tempo
oggi dopo quattro anni sono ancora qui e
continua a ridere aiuto anche altre
persone a farlo anche quando la vita non
ma esattamente come vorremmo ma una cosa
ho capito nel tempo che farmi stare bene
erano sì le risate ma soprattutto era
l'interazione giocosa con gli altri
è così che mi sono appassionato al tema
del gioco giocando e c'è la storia in
particolare che mi ha colpito molto e mi
ha fatto davvero rendere conto di quanto
giocare sia fondamentale e vitale per il
nostro benessere e la storia di questo
ragazzo qua charles whitman era un
giovane studente di ingegneria ex
tiratore scelto demarin che il primo
posto del 66 sale sulla torre
dell'università di austin in texas e
comincia a sparare sulla folla ucciderà
16 persone e le ferire gravemente 30
dando inizio alla tristemente famosa
stagione degli omicidi di massa in
america all'epoca stewart brown questo
psichiatra venne incaricato dallo stato
di scoprire quali fossero le ragioni per
cui persone apparentemente normali
all'improvviso diventavano dei serial
killer intervistò 26 detenuti
tutti i condannati per omicidio e scoprì
una cosa incredibile quasi tutti erano
stati dei privati dal gioco quando erano
bambini
purtroppo questa era la storia anche di
guida
padre che era un militare l'obbligo a
fare soltanto compiti utili mai a
giocare
da allora whitman ha intervistato più di
6000 persone e fondato il national
institute for play che studia appunto il
gioco ed è arrivato la conclusione
piuttosto inquietante anche la
deprivazione del gioco durante
l'infanzia può compromettere gravemente
la felicità e l'adattamento sociale una
volta che diventiamo adulti giocare è un
bisogno biologico primario è nato quasi
tutti gli animali giocano guardate qua
le caprette giocano le tigri e gli orsi
i lupi di palla e noi come esseri umani
siamo gli animali che giocano più di
tutti il bisogno di giocare e scritto
nei nostri geni perché perché ci
permette di sviluppare delle competenze
fisiche sociali emotive in un ambiente
sicuro
i cuccioli di leone ad esempio giocano
alla lotta per diventare dei bravi
calciatori senza dover rischiare la vita
noi cuccioli di uomo giochiamo per
introiettare queste competenze che
saranno fondamentali
una volta diventati adulti giocare è un
tratto dell'evoluzione a tutti gli
effetti e tanti di noi continuano a
farlo anche da grandi come lo facciamo
in tantissimi modi ad esempio c'è chi
gioca col gioco della scrittura che è un
gioco della fantasia con la pittura il
primo speaker gioca viaggiando chi con i
mirtilli come dicevamo prima è il nostro
un po il nostro hickey guy perché lo
facciamo
anzi no prima video questa cosa la neo
tenia cioè questo termine che sembra un
po la malattia non lo è una cosa molto
bella vuol dire letteralmente ritenzione
di tratti dell'immaturità noi riteniamo
questi tratti dalla nostra giovinezza
come la voglia di giocare perché ci
fanno bene appunto lo facciamo perché ci
dà dei superpoteri ci permette di
stringere relazioni di qualità e
durature nutre la nostra immaginazione
la creatività abbassa i livelli di
cortisolo riallinea gli ormoni dello
stress
inoltre la cooperazione ci insegnano
avere fiducia negli altri
in poche parole ci rende delle persone
più resilienti voglio vedere facce nere
un attimo le luci in sala
voglio vedere sì
tra di voi l'uci si considera una
persona giocosa tramite notato che sulla
bocca secca avrebbe un attimo un po
d'emozione
mammamia le prime file
come fate un pò paura benissimo grazie
non tutti giustamente sto scherzando
naturalmente forse non vi ritenete così
perché non sapete ancora cosa
a che gioco vi piace giocare ad ogni
modo ci sono delle persone play fobiche
che hanno proprio la fobia del gioco è
un ambiente nello specifico e polifonico
di tutti ed è il mondo del lavoro
lavorare per definizione è duro faticoso
quale la palla brava una cosa brutta no
considerata negativa perché ve lo dico
io
tanti motivi storico culturali quell 1
tra tutti è la prima rivoluzione
industriale con la meccanizzazione del
lavoro su troppo avanti poi arrabbia con
la meccanizzazione del lavoro il
dipendente diventa un ingranaggio
perfetto della macchina che è
l'organizzazione deve essere veloce
efficiente e parlare il meno possibile
giusto
oggi le cose sono un po cambiate ma
purtroppo il modello meccanicista è
ancora tanto diffuso per modello
meccanicistico intendo organizzazione
quale macchina dipendenti ingranaggi in
realtà l'azienda e all'organismo
evidente molto complesso che cambia di
continuo la demotivazione oggi ai
massimi storici e gli ambienti di lavoro
sono stato di frustrazione sfiduciare
ballo poi a generare conflitti più o
meno espliciti ecco in questo tipo di
ambienti giocare o qualsiasi eccesso di
allegria sono visti come una vera
minaccia perché perché osta e lavora o
della stessa passa per forza per fortuna
questo tipo di modello cominciato a
portar sono emerse delle clip una crisi
sempre più evidente e tante
organizzazioni hanno cominciato una
transizione verso modelli sempre più
sostenibili inclusivi umani perché
appunto ci siamo resi conto che le
aziende sono fatte di persone e non di
macchine oggi in italia nel mondo stanno
nascendo le cosiddette organizzazioni
positive sono aziende che hanno
realmente a cuore il benessere e la
felicità dei propri dipendenti e mi
sembra la sincronia bellissima che
proprio oggi in questo istante mentre
restiamo qui si stia formando la prima
classe
chief business officer i primi 50
manager della felicità italiani con
l'istituto italiano per le
organizzazioni positive con il quale
collaboro per portare le pratiche
giocose all'interno delle culture
aziendali
ecco vedete la mia ricerca in qualche
modo si incastra proprio qui in questa
linea ascendente che l'interesse reale
per l'umano
abbiamo detto che giocare è un bisogno
biologico primario ed è anche una
variabile della scienza della felicità
io con questo non voglio dire che
giocare sia la panacea di ogni male ma
sicuramente è un grande catalizzatore di
processi un enzima potentissimo al
servizio di clima cooperazione
motivazione creatività valori che
nessuna azienda che oggi vuole avere
successo può dimenticare sbagliata ecco
visto che sapevo lebran 20
ecco no mi sono dimenticata oggi voglio
svelarvi anche un segreto
importantissimo che vale 500 miliardi di
dollari che sono i soldi che ogni anno
l'america spende a causa della
demotivazione dei propri dipendenti
alzi la mano chi la mattina e lunedì
mattina è felicissimo di andare a
lavorare qualcuno c'è questo freelance
probabilmente persone che hanno trovato
il proprio i kig hai alzato ebbene
stamani non tantissimi perché perché le
aziende non hanno ancora capito quali
sono i veri fattori della motivazione
che li voglio far vedere questa è la sel
determination theory di rai e nei dieci
sono i fattori motivanti da un livello
che strinse con è intrinseco abbiamo la
pressione economica lavoro per soldi
molto basso
poi abbiamo la pressione emotiva lavoro
per avere un riconoscimento motivo cibo
e motivo abbiamo il potenziale lavoro
sono motivato a lavorare perché credo di
poterlo fare di avere il potenziale per
farlo abbiamo poi lo scopo sono state
modificate le slide ma non fa niente
lo scopo è lavoro per qualcosa che va al
di là della mia individualità qualcosa
di grande di me ma al primo posto che
non è quello che ci dovrebbe essere
scritto due ma non fa niente è signori
il gioco giocare martedì contro giocare
l'attività maggiore motivazione
intrinseca che esista quando gioco non
voglio fare nient'altro voglio fare
soltanto quello se l'azienda e capissero
che per motivare davvero i propri
dipendenti dovrebbero in sé portare
un po di cultura del divertimento e del
gioco forse risolverebbero i problemi in
maniera un po diversa
non è un caso se l 81 per cento dei
dipendenti di aziende di romina the
great grandi tra le 100 migliori aziende
per cui lavorare hanno detto di lavorare
un ambiente fan divertente ma allora
forse cominciamo a capire che giocare
non è proprio sinonimo di perdere tempo
giocare per un atteggiamento mentale
completamente diverso che vanno tenere
clima cooperazione motivazione appunto
dei nostri dipendenti
le persone ci hanno voglia di fare bene
il proprio lavoro se li facciamo stare
bene giocare quindi alla cosa molto
seria e adesso secondo me nella vostra
testa ci saranno un sacco di
interrogativi fichissime tutte queste
cose che mi sta dicendo lucia ma quindi
che dovrei fare io non me ne vado a
lavorare organizza la partita a ruba
bandiera metto il naso rosso in sono
ancora coltre barzellette manco io
tranquilli non bisogna essere per forza
persone divertenti questo mito da
sfatare non bisogna essere degli
umoristi nati per saper giocare io per
esempio non capiscono le battute lo
capisco è vero quindi ho provato a
stilare una serie di quattro principi
che forse possono ritardi e portare
anche solo un pizzico di cultura del
gioco il premio è il primo principio è
non esistono taglia unica non esiste uno
stile di gioco uguale per tutti
ognuno di noi né uno diverso se ci fosse
una ricetta io vedrei volentieri ma non
c'è dovete cercarle a voi quali sono gli
ingredienti per il vostro team quindi la
parola chiave per questo principio è
chiedere dovete chiedere informarvi
scoprire cosa passione dipendenti come
fate a fare delle cose che mi fanno bene
a loro se non sapete cosa amano fare
dovete interessarvi genuinamente a loro
questa azione da sola fa miracoli
miracoli
secondo principio da del buon esempio
io capisco che vieni al tiro
dell'organizzazione facciamo un po
fatica una certa questa del gioco che la
paura di mettersi in ridicolo potrebbe
essere alta però una brutta notizia
non c'è modo di chiedere a qualcuno ai
propri dipendenti di diventare giocosi
gioiosi allegri se non siamo noi i primi
a sostenere il processo dobbiamo fare in
modo che la leggerezza penetri poco a
poco all'interno dell'organizzazione e
non dobbiamo pensare neanche di fare
chissà cosa sapete cosa basterebbe un
sorriso
in più una pacca sulla spalla la
sorpresa inaspettata lo sguardo sincero
ma dobbiamo fare noi siamo noi gli
agenti del cambiamento e soprattutto il
terzo principio il cambiamento ha
bisogno di tempo non possiamo pensare
che nel giro di una settimana la nostra
azienda diventi una fucina di
divertimento produttività e creatività
quando non lo è mai stata prima dobbiamo
essere pazienti cercare diano piano le
soluzioni sfruttare la fantasia
naturalmente stiamo uscendo fuori dalla
zona di comfort e quindi non per forza
le azioni che sceglieremo all'inizio se
vogliamo intraprendere questo cammino
che so essere difficile non
funzioneranno non potete a battermi
perché ogni cambiamento che duraturo nel
tempo è lento ultimo work heartbreak no
grazie work hart lane hard forse l'avete
sentito lo dicono un sacco nella silicon
valley lavora duramente in gioco
duramente la nostra lavorarsi allora e
poi la boxe thai giocasse ha giocato che
è un po in italiano
anzi marchigiano 16 lug un d'inghiltera
condicio ti faccio lavora e poi dopo
puoi andare a giocare io non credo in
questo credo che il gioco il lavoro
siano due dimensioni che debbano
compenetrarsi non può essere il gioco il
contraltare del lavoro ma lo spirito che
aziende spendono una fortuna per i team
building che è giocare fuori dal lavoro
poi però quando tornano è tutto uguale a
prima la formazione del team dovrebbe
essere una prerogativa quotidiana non è
un caso se le più grandi aziende di
software quelle più all'avanguardia
hanno installato dei tavoli da ping pong
e dei miliardi negli uffici o se google
permette propri dipendenti di portare i
cani nel posto di lavoro lo stesso
richard branson il fondatore del gruppo
virgin dice che il segreto è successo
alla sua azienda sia solo uno il
divertimento
possiamo fare tantissime cose e proprio
forse perché le possiamo fare tanto è
difficile scegliere però davvero dovete
usare la fantasia a capire cosa piace al
vostro team e provare senza avere paura
potete ad esempio creare un rito
divertente per il cambio turno oppure
scegliere un giorno a settimana in cui
vi vestite in maniera un po stravagante
o ancora
mare insieme al vostro tipo un obiettivo
raggiunto insieme e celebrare
importantissimo dovete solo usare la
fantasia e far sì che il divertimento
entri a far parte di eventi un valore
della cultura aziendale lei la mia capra
e vi invita a giocare abbiamo tanto
parlato di gioco scusate e quindi è
servito a giocare chi non ha alzato la
mano prima esso mi odia ma tranquilli
perché sarà breve indolore vi devo
presentare tre amici che sono la tigre
la tigre e chi siamo nella vita
la persona che nonostante i problemi
alla paura affronta la vita siamo pronti
latika fa così pronti
guardate fatelo anche voi pre 21 via i
fuochi d'artificio sono la creatività
quei colori riescono al cervello
la capacità di trovare soluzioni
creative sostenibili ai problemi che poi
affronta al tigre
i colori sono così i fuochi d'artificio
wow mappa quanti si metteva i bravissimi
e infine c'è la persona le relazioni
quello senza le relazioni tutto il resto
non avrebbe nessun senso l'intelligenza
emotiva e così sintetizzata così vai
ripassiamo tigre pochi artificio
persona alzatevi in piedi
adesso vi metterete schiena contro
schiena con la persona più vicino a voi
vai velocemente che abbiamo poco tempo
la persone persone che rimangono sole
alzino la mano velocemente così vi vedo
chi rimane da solo
guardatevi accoppiatevi vedetevi
trovatevi tra di voi velocemente correte
a incontro bene adesso silenzio un
attimo che vi spiego cosa farete
inspirate profondamente respirate
profondamente di connettete con la
persona dietro di voi e pensaci bla bla
dovete pensare a uno di questi tre
simboli o la tigre o la persona e fuochi
d'artificio
ci siete la cosa però che dovete fare è
connettervi davvero con la persona
dietro di voi e trova a provare a
install instaurare un contatto
telepatico dovete riuscire a fare lo
stesso simbolo della persona quando vi
dirò il 3d girerete scoprirete se ce
l'avete fatta installare questo
instaurare questo contatto telepatico
siete pronti
silenzio è naturalmente se ce la fate
reazione strappa i capelli c'è proprio
mamma mia dovete celebrare abbiamo detto
che la celebrazione importante quindi
batti cinque vi prendete in braccio baci
abbracci no cose so se ma tutto il resto
è accettabile pronti ci siete inspirate
con le chiudete gli occhi connettetevi
sta instaurando un interazione
telepatica tigre persona o fuochi
d'artificio 321 via giratevi
[Applauso]
fantastico
come è andata a chi ce l'ha fatta alzi
la mano
[Applauso]
voi siete un po più fortunati questa
lampo meno ce l'avete fatta anche voi
tanti tantissimi bravissimi fatemi
l'applauso sedetevi vi dico un'ultima
cosa me ne vado c'è sempre un po di
scompiglio dopo tigre persona fuochi
d'artificio uno scompiglio felice
signori bla bla
la leggerezza la leggerezza alla
competenza fondamentale in questo futuro
che emerge è che cambia la velocità
della luce
ogni piccolo cambiamento ci rende dei
passenger degli autostoppisti
intergalattici
il viaggio che io vi propongono da un
pianeta in cui il gioco è il rischio da
evitare è un altro pianeta in cui gli
sguardi i sorrisi sono la norma
un pianeta in cui non abbiamo paura di
essere tigri persone fuochi d'artificio
un pianeta in cui siamo felici
non siamo felici quando abbiamo successo
esattamente il contrario cominciamo ad
avere successo proprio perché siamo
felici perché la felicità e il gioco
sono delle competenze vanno allenate
stasera quando tornate a casa penserete
a queste cose a tutti gli special
io sono contenta se proverete a portare
anche solo un pizzico di cultura del
divertimento nei vostri posti di lavoro
sia che siate dei manager dei sì o dei
dipendenti qualsiasi cosa siate però
prima di fare questo vi chiedo un favore
spegnete i cellulari e giocate
soprattutto coi vostri figli perché
davvero importante ce ne hanno un gran
bisogno ragazzi buttate le per terra e
giocate con loro grazie
[Applauso]